welcome back rocky caught up with a
local real estate guru
who is all about faith empowerment and
luxury
nasheed welcome to las vegas now ah
thank you for having me
of course a whole lot of beauty and
brains on this zoom call right now i
can't wait to talk to you about all of
these awards i see behind you and i
understand you won
best of las vegas 2020 yes i
won the gold best of las vegas 2020
and i was actually really shocked um
i was up against a lot of
you know great brokers in town luxury
brokers and brokerages
and i kind of didn't even want to try
but then i'm like you know
i need to try i need to go for it
absolutely deserving i understand you
have a license
in nevada and california so just tell us
a little bit about your business and
what you do
for all of us here yeah so i've been
doing real estate in vegas
for 15 years since 2006 i
recently opened my brokerage in
southern california and i have some
luxury listings there
and clients there and you know it just
made sense since we have
so many people from california right now
moving here
so it's like you know you can sell their
property there work with them here as a
buyer
so it's worked throughout really well
thankfully and
what i love most about you know all of
your success is that you give back
to the community as well let's talk
about what you donate um
through your commission so it's really
important for me to after every closing
to donate a percentage of my commissions
to different foundations right now i'm
associated with
nevada childhood cancer foundation uh so
after every closing i give them a
portion
and also my test rescue she rescues dogs
so
i just kids and dogs you know now let's
talk about your clientele
who who do you help here in las vegas
uh so you know i've been doing this 15
years so
i'm a little bit more specific with who
i choose to take on i love to work
you know with good people with integrity
and then you know luxury properties or
investors that buy in bowl
i'm looking at your place right now
which is very luxurious and beautiful
what does las vegas have to offer these
days
vegas still offers you know that big
city life that excitement and properties
are still
not as expensive as other big cities you
know like la new york chicago
yes but yeah and you still have like a
great fun
city but the prices are going up it's
getting there just because
inventory is so low you love to empower
women through your business as well
let's talk about that
i feel like i have a story and i love to
share my story
to be able to you know let women know
that
you too can also have you know the
success you want
the love life you want you can have
everything that you want
you just have to you know it just goes
so much deeper you have to have like a
certain level of faith
integrity work on yourself and never
give up never
settle for less and you really can have
whatever you dream of
give mushid a call at 702-769-6274
or visit masheed.com for more
las vegas now we'll be right back